finally after over a year of absolutely
nothing
from software have revealed new content
for secular
come october 29th you'll be able to play
secure in a few new ways
you'll be able to rematch bosses you've
already defeated
you'll be able to switch outfits to
something different at the sculptor's
idol
and you'll be able to unlock these rare
outfits by completing
single life challenges which are trials
that have yet to be revealed
furthermore they're adding an online
feature to the game for the first time
where you'll be able to view the ghosts
of those who came before you
so let's go into this in more detail and
also speculate on what this could mean
for the future of the series
whether that's dlc or a sequel so
sakura has always had a theme of
revisiting memories
like you did in herata or when you
defeat a boss
but now you can actually replay the
entire boss fight
in what's being called reflections of
strength
these are accessible at the sculptors
idle and from software says that you're
going to want to do this
because you're going to want to practice
for the new no
death run challenges that they're adding
to the game
really coincidentally i actually just
finished in no death run of sakura and
i actually used a boss rush mod in order
to practice
all of the fights and they're adding
both of those things to the game now
which is a crazy
coincidence really the boss rush mod
that already exists
gives you currency every time you beat a
boss so that you can buy prosthetic
weapons and consumables and
progress in that way but the real value
of this mod is that it helps you become
absolutely familiar with every boss and
that's exactly what you need to do in
this game in order to set yourself
up for success in a no death run so if
you want to prepare
for from software's no death run
challenge coming at the end of this
october
consider downloading this mod or watch
my recent twitch stream
in the description for some tips on how
to go deathless
these deathless challenges are going to
be called
gauntlets of strength and they're going
to be single life challenges where if
you die you have to start over from the
beginning
we don't know what the gauntlets will
consist of exactly
maybe for example one challenge might
ask you to get to the end of the game
without dying
perhaps one of the gauntlets might ask
you to defeat all bosses
without dying or maybe a selection of
bosses without dying
but whatever these gauntlets consist of
we do know that they relate to bosses in
some way at least because
the devs want you to practice bosses for
these challenges
and we do know that there are at least
two types of gauntlet because
successfully completing one will reward
you with one
of three new cosmetic outfits they've
revealed that one of the reward outfits
is called tengu
another is called old ashina and the
third outfit
is something that's unlocked when you
simply beat the game once
now having outfits is one thing for the
replayability of the game
and it's something that pc players have
had access to for a really long time and
a lot of these outfits are really good
but it's another thing entirely to have
these skins
tied to challenges in game in my recent
stream
i actually mentioned exactly that i
talked about how the idea of tying skins
to a meaningful challenge
gives these games so much more
replayability and
from software delivered on that all we
needed was some sort of post-game
content to make this game
worth coming back to because just
thinking about the gameplay alone
secure is worth replaying mastering
bosses and mastering combat in this game
is kind of a thrill that no other souls
game can give you in my opinion you just
start to fight on a whole nother level
once you really practice this game
and i'm super excited to stream this
experience with you guys
next month yes it is weird that from
software are
updating sakura after a year and a half
of
nothing at all for this game but man
it's kind of smart in a way
for relatively little effort the game is
going to have
its online presence temporarily revived
on places like twitch and
a lot of people might be coming from
ghost of tsushima which was released
recently
and they might be looking for new things
to try
having one mode of difficulty in these
games does
really help the social experience of
playing this game
and sharing it with others because we're
all playing the exact same game
and we're connected by that fact but now
secure is
officially an online game with the new
edition of
remnants so according to the blog post
remnants are recordings of what a player
does in game for up to 30 seconds at a
time
and they're available for use after the
game's tutorial after a player records
their remnant
whether it's an epic takedown of an
enemy or a flawless demonstration of a
tricky movement technique
it can be uploaded with a written
message so that other community members
can play it back
so for those seeking guidance on how to
beat something or looking for hidden
items
the hope is that these records might
prove a blessing
and if a community member watches one of
your remnants and then rates it
the owner will have their hp recovered
for free which allows you to get back
into the fight
without having to heal or rest at a
sculptor's idol
so this is the sort of addition that
does make sekido a bit more
accessible to new players it's not much
but with this
new players might be able to see what
experienced players are doing to succeed
and they might be able to see what
inexperienced players are doing to fail
in the recent video we also talked about
how sakura could use more stuff like
this
and it's one that makes the game online
no less
for a long time sakura pc has actually
had a really good
online mod it adds co-op and pvp to the
game which
is an amazing community creation and
it's super fun with your friends
but there are definitely moments in this
mod that made me understand why they
made secure
a single player experience so finally
what does this mean for the future of
the ip they announced that the game has
sold more than 5 million copies now
and it convincingly won game of the year
last year
it's also really well primed for dlc or
sequel content
based on the character tomaway or
regarding the
journey to the west that's referenced in
one of the endings
so the question we have to ask now is
are these quality of life additions to
the game
just a way to temporarily revive it or
are they something more regardless
subscribe and stay tuned
also check out our sakura inspired merch
that went live last week
i've temporarily made the limited red
kanji edition
available again for a couple of days so
if you need a new hoodie or a new
t-shirt go and check it out
in the description thanks for watching
and i'll see you back in sakura
on october 29th
you